well we got some wonderful news
yesterday as I'm sure you heard
Justice Kennedy's retirement is great
fantastic news and I'm surprised by it
III admit that I'm surprised I really
figured that he would wait at least
until after the midterms to retire so
that he doesn't become the most hated
man um you know in Washington at least
among the Liberals and the media and so
forth but he did retire and you know I
said as recent as recently as yesterday
I had said that I don't think we're
heading into a civil war in this country
and the thing that in my mind would
prevent a civil war is that Americans
are very lazy and also you can't really
get air conditioning and Wi-Fi on the
battlefield
so I figured that would be kind of our
saving grace that would prevent an
actual war from taking place
but then Kennedy retired and now we are
looking at the very real though far from
certain possibility of roe v-- wade
being overturned and the phantom right
to abortion being voided from the books
this of course would not be the same as
outlawing abortion by the way and I know
that this is probably really obvious to
most of you but some people seem to be
confused on this point this to overturn
roe v wade is not to outlaw abortion
that would not outlaw abortion to outlaw
abortion nationwide would require
probably an amendment a personhood
amendment or something like that but a
SCOTUS decision would be hugely
significant it would be one of the
greatest moments in American history by
far though it wouldn't be the end of the
pro-life fight it would really it would
it would actually be more like the
beginning of the pro-life fight the way
that somebody on Twitter said I thought
they'd put her - they put it in a way
that's very apt I think and he said that
the overturning of roe v wade would be
like d-day okay so it's not the end of
World War two it is d-day it is like
storming the beaches
okay here's when the real fight starts
and it's important for us to understand
this this is not me trying to downplay
the significance of overturning roe v
wade I mean I would I would literally
weep for joy if that happened I would
weep for joy for days if that happened
but what would then happen is that all
the states would have the ability to
outlaw it if they if they chose to and
so immediately upon this decision coming
down if it were to come down abortion
would still be legal in every state in
the Union and then each state would have
to go through and explicitly outlaw it
themselves and we know that there's a
good chunk of states where that's just
not gonna happen
states like you know California New York
it's not gonna happen but then there are
other states where it could happen and
that's where there's gonna be a real
fight okay that's where there's gonna be
a battle like you've never seen before
and that's where the culture war I think
could bubble over into something like a
real war and it's just a wee tweak you
cannot understate
or you cannot overstate
the way liberals will react if their
right to abortion is actually threatened
and this is not me at all saying oh well
you know maybe we shouldn't do it
because I'm afraid of how liberal know
this is they will explode
perhaps literally in some way and if
that's the case so be it
because there is no price there is no
price that is too high to pay when it
comes to finally doing away with this
historic atrocity
and so of overturning roe v wade and
beginning to actually outlaw abortion if
that did bubble over into violent
hostility because the left just cannot
handle it then I say so be it so be it
this is what we have to understand it's
something I've been saying for a long
time I wrote a whole book on the subject
in fact abortion is the left's highest
sacrament that's what I call it it's
it's their high saccharine sacrament
it's the most important thing to them
it's it's it's the thing that is most
central to their ideology into their
outlook on life
the modern left was really born with Roe
and it won't die with the overturning of
Roe but it will enter into a new phase a
phase that is even darker more depraved
more wicked and probably more violent
than the phase that they're currently in
and there's a reason why abortion is so
important to the left we need it we need
to understand the reason it's a very
simple reason
modern leftism is the worship of the
self
is the worship of the south and in that
sense it is not you know some people
will say well modern leftism is not the
same as classical liberalism the two
completely different things and they are
two different things but they're not two
completely different things with
classical liberalism and the
Enlightenment the seeds were planted for
what we now call modern leftism the
seeds were planted and they sprouted
into this disgusting hideous thing
called leftism and now what defines the
left is its belief in the supremacy of
the self
the self is supreme
I get to decide not me personally but I
as in the self I get to decide what is
right what is wrong what is true what is
false everything is relative to my
desires my feelings my needs my
proclivities my lifestyle I can even
change my own biological makeup if I
want to I can I can change my very
identity just on the strength of my
desire
that's what modern left this belief
the south is the highest life form the
highest good
and that is why liberalism is I have
said that liberalism is Satan's
liberalism is kind of a secular Satan
and I don't say that is an insult I mean
I don't say it as a compliment either
but it's it's not don't mean it just as
an insult it's just it's just true lit
at this point you can't it's hard to
distinguish liberalism from Satanism and
if you were to go to a satanic temple
which I don't recommend but if you were
to go to a satanic temple and you hear
what's being said it would sound an
awful lot like what you would hear at a
DNC convention
Satanist themselves will tell you I've
gotten into some Twitter spats with the
Satanic temple or whatever the official
satanic religion is and they're very you
know they want to make it very clear
from a PR perspective they're very
they're very eager to inform you that
they don't worship Satan they don't
believe in safe
rather they worship what Satan himself
worshiped which is the south
Satan worshipped himself the self
and so that's what the modern Satanists
worship as well not Satan not him say
but the self
which means that they are also
worshipping Satan they just don't know
it they worship the the mighty me you
know me I the the I the self Aleister
Crowley the famous Satanist an occultist
said the way he put it was do what thou
wilt shall be the whole of the law
so in other words just the hope do what
you want you know that's the that's the
only that's the only moral law is just
do what you want and if anything could
be considered arguably immoral it would
be to refrain from doing what you want
that's a that's you know that that is
the only the only perversion is to
exercise self-restraint
and this is also how liberals fields
it's the same idea now here's the other
point in this world where there is no
god but the individual then the whole
point really of life is pleasure there's
if there if there is no God and there is
no objective morality there's no
objective truth then the only point of
life is just to have fun and to
accumulate possessions and experience
and wealth but mainly to enjoy yourself
and to and to have pleasure
well if pleasure is the point of life
then the most pleasurable thing sex is
now the centerpiece of existence it is
the point of the point and therefore the
worst thing that anyone could possibly
do is impose limitations on your sex
life because your sex life is your life
you don't you don't draw a distinction
between your life and your sex life it's
the same thing and for someone to
intrude on your sex life in your mind
interfere with it impose restraints or
confines or anything well then they're
doing that to you as a person they're
doing it to your entire life and the
greatest
the greatest limitation
but in the minds of a leftist the worst
limitation is the one that comes
naturally with sex itself and that is
the formation of new life
so the point of life is pleasure
greatest pleasure is sex worst thing you
could do therefore is limit sex and the
worst limitation on sex is the fact that
it naturally creates people and so now
the creation of people is treated like
you know like a disease like like it's
not the natural outcome of sex but but
more some kind of some kind of mutation
and then the pill you know the birth
control pill becomes like this miracle a
new kind of miracle really because the
old miracles were all about restoring
life healing life but this one prevents
life that's the new the new miracle
prevents life from happening and we say
oh that's a miracle
but abortion abortion is the ultimate
birth control and also at the same time
the ultimate expression of the supremacy
of the individual of the self the
ultimate expression of a woman's
liberation liberation from motherhood
liberation from morality liberation from
from responsibility liberation from her
child
and her child of course represents all
of those things her child represents
responsibility morality motherhood of
course up so so her child is the
embodiment of that which makes her child
her enemy and in destroying it
exercises her dominance and her power
abortion fortifies sex as a purely
pleasure-seeking endeavor and at the
same time it codifies into law the
relativism and self worship of modern
leftist it is the foundation of the
left's entire movement and with abortion
the left has seized finally it's
god-like that godlike power it is always
craved the godlike power over life and
death the power to assert the the
desires of the individual over the needs
and the very life of the other
so
they cannot let it go
they cannot they want
this is everything if they let that go
they give up everything
and they will fight with a ruthlessness
that you have never seen before they
will lie they will cheat they will
destroy they will kill I mean they've
been killing all along they've killed 60
million babies so they don't have any
moral qualms about
if anything could spark
if anything could spark a new civil war
in this country
then I think this would be it
but more likely is the situation I
talked about yesterday where
when we think of Civil War we think of
our mind goes to the sit-in the Civil
War of 1861 when you 'no forms
well the south didn't always have
uniforms but or shoes but you have the
two sides marching fort towards each
other in formation and then they're
shooting muskets at each other in
cannonballs I don't think we're gonna be
especially the muskets and cannibals I
don't think we're looking at a civil war
like that could be something more more
akin to what I talked about yesterday
which is just kind of chaos and anarchy
in the streets like what we've already
seen in Baltimore and Ferguson and other
places except that
across the nation
and
involving perhaps this time
guns and and and lasting for a lot a lot
longer I mean I don't know I that that's
what I worry might could happen
and I think that you could argue we've
been on that trajectory for a while now
I talked about yesterday the powder kegs
right we're sitting on certain powder
kegs well maybe this is the biggest
powder keg of all and if that goes off
who knows what happens
I say all of this just as means of just
in the interests of
us preparing ourselves
and looking honestly at the situation
where it's not going to be as simple as
overturn roe v-- wade abortion is gone
array now there will be a array if they
overturn roe v-- wade believe me
but then there's going to be a real
fight
as I said at the top so be it
fight that fight
that is a fight worth fighting
100%
no hesitation
but we have to get to that point first
and
you know and and and the other the other
wrinkle here last thing I'll say the
other wrinkle is
now this is going to require
Republicans there's going to be pressure
on Republicans like they've never seen
and so the Republicans are going to have
to vote to confirm a justice who could
overturn roe v wade and that's gonna
require real actual backbone encouraged
from Republicans as I can't even say
backbone courage and Republican in the
same sentence without laughing so that's
what it's gonna require for the first
time in decades it's gonna require
actual courage from the Republican Party
this time to approve a justice who could
overturn roe v wade and and to do it
right before a midterm election and I
hope they have that kind of courage I
would not at all take it for granted
that they all do liberals would only
need a couple of of cowardly Republicans
to defect and there are more than a
couple cowardly Republicans it's more
like there are a couple courageous ones
in the wrestler couch so
so this is not at all you know this is
this is not all something we take take
for granted
and this means that we as conservatives
and pro-lifers we have to be putting the
pressure on the Republicans like you
better do the right thing
the message from liberals is going to be
well if you if you vote to confirm a you
know a conservative justice we're gonna
see to it that you're voted out of
office
well our message to Republicans need to
be if you dare now our message needs to
be if you dare defect on this if you
dare drop this ball you are finished
your political career is over you will
never we will never vote for you for any
office ever again you're done
it is Unforgiven see unforgivable sin
there is nothing you could do after that
point to redeem yourself you're finished
and so that's our message that's our
message has to be the Republicans
you do the right thing here or you we
are exiling you into the wilderness and
that is it there's no coming back from
it
so batten down the hatches folks things
could get ugly
we're fighting for life
we're on the right side we are we are
definitively clearly on the right side
and so whatever has to happen
to fight for what's right well
that's just gonna be it's just going to
be what it is
thanks for watching everybody
I think I just broke my globe
and repair it
have a good day